économie l'ouverture du salon du
tourisme à paris
tendance 2002 elle n'est pas nouvelle
mais elle s'accentue l'engouement pour
les courts séjours
un week end ou à peine plus 11 septembre
oblige c'est l'europe qui est à la mode
isabelle quintin philippe chasselas les
bagages les prospectus rien ne manque
pour ce week end entre un partout à
prague après les jours de congé avec la
rtt que nous a permis
prendre ces trois jours supplémentaires
en dehors de nos jours de congés partir
du mercredi au samedi soit quatre jours
à prague amsterdam ou encore marrakech
ce n'est plus tout à fait un week end
est pas encore des vacances c'est un
court séjour ce que les voyagistes
appelle l'effet 35 heures le temps de
loisirs est beaucoup plus grand que
l'essentiel de la ville aux normes les
plus consacrée au travail il ya 50 ans 1
% de l'espérance de vie était consacrée
au travail aujourd'hui 9 % de
l'espérance de vie des hommes français
consacré au travail
donc on a créé des voyages à thèmes que
ce soit sur paris sur des régions de
france et sur l'europe notamment dans
les capitales européennes où des
expositions des voyages culturels sont
créés grâce à ces logiques de clients
nouveaux depuis vingt ans le nombre de
courts séjours a doublé et aujourd'hui
elles étaient 35 heures le marché
explose
l'année dernière il s'est ainsi vendu
plus de voyages en avril qu'en été